this week on brian ross investigate
an investigative reporter takes on
georgia's new election law
right after this law was passed there
was a revival of a challenge to the
votes of
364 000 georgia voters asking how this
one local republican party official
was able to personally challenge the
eligibility of some
32 000 voters and you have crossed
the line you have crossed the line get
out of my house
now i shall get out of your house before
i throw you and and you are sure that
this is your legal voting address
plus what's in store for former
minneapolis police officer
derek shover being sentenced to prison
this week
we'll hear from a current inmate i hate
to say this but i would say
you're probably going to try to kill her
and we'll talk with a former warrior
so this is going to be very hard time
for dear children
it really is it's going to be hard time
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of media islands
some of your campaign supporters are
suggesting somehow
that by doing this it works to suppress
the vote i'm not sure i understand how
that works
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague at law and crime
ronda schwartz and ronda we begin with a
new investigative report
out of georgia and what might be called
the great purge
the georgia secretary of state says his
office is going to remove
some 100 000 people from the voter
registration lists
people he says have not been active have
not voted in some time
but there's yet another purge being
demanded this one by republican party
officials in georgia
who say they are now challenging the
eligibility
of some 360 000 voters something they
say they can legally do
under georgia's new voting laws rhonda
that's right brian and now comes
investigative reporter greg palast
with backing from the progressive tom
hartman report
with a new investigation looking into
who's behind all this
and how they're using a new provision in
georgia's new state voting law
to challenge so many voters claiming
they've changed addresses they moved out
of state
all without it seems any personal
knowledge or investigation
into the underlying facts brian to learn
more about this we're joined now by
investigative reporter greg palace with
the palace investigative fund
greg tell us about this new provision in
the georgia voting rights law
the the new georgia law says that any
any citizen of georgia can challenge
another voter an unlimited number of
voters
the precise language from the law there
shall not be a limit on the number of
persons
whose qualifications such elector may
challenge
and right after this law was passed
there was a revival
of a challenge to the votes of 364
thousand georgia voters
and who made these challenges well there
are 88
uh operatives of a group called true the
vote now almost all of them were
republican officials of one type or
another
we had in in 88 counties we had
one official who personally challenged
32
000 voters that was this woman pamela
reardon
a cobb county republican party official
who told palace how she got the 32
thousand voters names to challenge
from a conservative group called true
the vote
which researches change of address data
nationwide
they're out of texas and they work on
this constantly and they've been doing
it for over 10 years
so true the vote gave you the list or
they had been working on the list with a
couple other organizations
to vet it and then the other challenge
is the list i got from the guy that's
been working through it
to get every single one of them vetted
so we're working on that she claims that
she knows for a fact that these are
voters
ineligible to vote but when palace
showed her photos of the two of the 32
000 voters she challenged do you know
this woman that
do you recognize that woman um not
offhand
i don't you never spoke to her no no
what about this
guy and his wife on his honeymoon do you
recognize that man
no and in fact did not know
any of the voters she challenged whether
they were eligible or not
did you ever speak to storm soul no i
told you already i did not speak in
to the 32 000 people yet she had
certified she knew as a fact they were
not
legal voters that's correct she never
called anyone
she never wrote anyone she never did any
you know
personal investigation and neither did
any of the other 88
who challenge a third of a million
voters just no no attempt to do this
correctly at all
if the counties accept the challenges
officials are required to send postcards
to notify all those voters their
eligibility
has been challenged i i did not try to
stop them from voting
that you challenged excuse me that is uh
you you
are you know no no you're making up a
story here
you are making a story which is wrong
okay okay the challenge is you take it
in there and say
according to the national change of
address these people
have changed their address so check it
out
so i didn't challenge them per se and
she was not happy with the outcome of
the interview
no she wasn't no i'm done i'm done
because you are not listening to me
and you are putting words in my mouth
which is not even
no you sir get out of my head okay i
will get out of your house
and you are not listening to me okay do
you know that you could go
to prison do you understand that under
the ku klux klan law of 1871 get out
and you have crossed the line you have
crossed the line get out of my house
now i shall get out of your house before
i throw you
and you are sure that this is your legal
voting address
so what about these voters do they know
they've been challenged and how do they
uh sort of make sure they can vote
legally
well two things uh the ones we spoke to
said they were shocked and stunned
because they never got any uh contact
from
ms reardon or from the uh true the vote
or anyone
now reardon says that she wanted the
county to send out
postcards to all these people and now
here according to the aclu which is
which is uh
opposing which was shocked when they
heard that they're reviving this
attempt to challenge these voters
they said look um the lawyer for the
aclu told us
that you have to have some care some
personal knowledge you you know you
can't just willy-nilly
uh remove voters from the voter rolls
now here's what they have to do if you
want to get back on
you must go to your county clerk's
office you have to
see that you got a card you have to go
to the county clerk's office
and prove you are who you are and live
where you live there's a day of work and
most
people very few people will respond to
that card
in fact the aclu was worried that people
would because you'd have
thousands of people jamming into these
clerks offices if this goes ahead
during a pandemic in these small offices
not a good idea
so as it stands now for those more than
three hundred thousand voters they're
off the rolls or they have to
prove they are eligible well that's it
we'll see because
right now the county is supposed to be
sending out those postcards and each of
those voters is going to have to come in
and verify who they are
or the next time they cast a ballot
it'll be thrown in the garbage
it won't count all right greg palace
investigative reporter or
palos foundation thank you so much for
being here tonight
uh you're very welcome brian and
there'll be a further report
in the guardian where i've been covering
elections thank you
we reached out to that republican woman
pamela riddim for a comment and rhonda
how did that go well brian in a phone
call that lasted about a minute pamela
raregan told me
everything she did was legal anyone can
do it it's all based on public post
office change of address records
she told me she threw greg palace out of
her house because he clearly did not
know the law and had
obtained the interview under false
pretenses uh
palace says his team asked her for an
interview about her political candidacy
and never promised to ask only puff
questions and
they left when asked
all right well coming up next on brian
ross investigates
with the sentencing of former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
set for this friday we'll talk with a
current inmate
and a former warden about what chauvin
faces
behind bars you're watching brian ross
investigates
the law and crime trial network
former minneapolis police officer
derrick chauvin is set to be sentenced
to prison this friday
and prosecutors are asking for a kind of
throw the book at him kind of sentence
rhonda
that's right brian while minnesota's
state guidelines would normally mean a
sentence range of 10 to 15 years
prosecutors have asked for a sentence of
30 years for derek chovin
citing aggravating circumstances
including
particular egregious cruelty of the
crime
and carrying it out in front of children
brian
we're joined now by michael j moore
who's an inmate
in a prison in washington state and also
a freelance writer
michael thank you so much for joining us
this evening tell me from your point of
view
what's it going to be like for an
officer like derek shovin to serve time
behind bars what happens to police once
they're in prison
i have to say that his experience would
be terrible
he would be an instant target how so
so the national security prisons are
obviously
on the inmate from our ran by gang
they're they're going to send somebody
after them automatically they're going
to
send somebody to stab them or a couple
people to beat them up
so for derek sheldon it's going to be um
clearly it's going to be worse he's
going to go in people are going to
recognize them instantly
and i would uh jesus i i hate to say
this but i would say that
you're probably going to try to kill him
really because he's an officer a former
police officer
not just because he's a former police
officer but because his case is so
high profile so what happens is
the guys in here they um they earn a lot
of
points i guess you would say with
whatever their affiliation is
um for things like that so they're going
to see a guy like sheldon and
they're not just going to want to hurt
him they're going to want to really hurt
him
they'll probably try to kill him and are
there gangs that would support a police
officer
behind bars absolutely not
no that's not a uh that's not a thing
in any prison that i've ever heard of
so from your point of view derek chovin
faces some
tough time behind bars really tough yeah
he's gonna have a very negative
experience and it's
probably something that shouldn't happen
once they put him in prison he's already
serving his sense right
and um what advice would you give to
derek chauvin
uh as he prepares to go to prison
what is there any advice that would keep
him safe do you think
you know i i i hate to say it it's a
bleak reality for a guy like him but
there
is really nothing he can do except um
as soon as he gets to prison he needs to
explain to the first person
that he sees that works within the
prison administration that he needs to
be in protective custody
they're gonna know that already um that
that's really all there is for a guy
like him
michael moore i want to thank you so
much for joining us and for your
insights
from behind the bars
yeah brian thank you for having me
anytime
to get more on this we're now joined by
a former warden cameron lindsay who
served in the federal system
across the country and also in a number
of private prisons
mr lindsay thank you so much for being
here let's begin by having your
description
of what happens to police officers when
they end up behind bars
well brian uh thank you for having me
police officers have to be treated very
carefully when they come into the system
for
safety and security purposes one could
argue
that derek shavan is america's most
hated person so therefore the minnesota
department of corrections
will will have a challenge in in terms
of ensuring his
his safety and security and do you think
they'll be inmates who will be out to
get him
i don't think there's any question about
it um he is just too big of a target
and so nuts and bolts what does a warden
do in that situation
nuts and bolts brian i i believe that uh
unequivocally they're going to have to
place him in some type of protective
custody stat
he will be in in some type of um some
type of of
isolation uh solitary confinement if you
will will he will
he will expect to be locked down
probably 23 hours a day with
with one hour a day devoted to
recreation
but they they being the minnesota doc
does have a responsibility to safeguard
him and i think the only way to do that
is is to keep him single-celled
throughout the duration of his
incarceration and do you also have to
keep an eye as a warden on a possible
suicide
absolutely you do um the doc
should have mental health professionals
checking on
on this individual as as they would on
on all
inmates um and everybody realizes the
sensitive nature of this case there are
many many people who would like to see
derek javen dead but that
in my mind is irrelevant we have a
constitutional obligation
to ensure that our systems of justice
are upheld and that means
ensuring the safety and security of
every inmate
that is incarcerated so this is going to
be very hard time for derek sheldon
it really is it's going to be hard time
and the thing about solitary confinement
is i i used to be a believer in it and
used it at
times but i i do not believe in it any
longer for any kind of long-term
purposes
unquestionably uh it causes uh mental
illness
and those who already have mental
illnesses it exacerbates those mental
illnesses so
i am not a proponent of of
uh solitary confinement especially in
the long term
so it's it's going to take some
creativity in terms of
of how mr chavin should be should be
managed uh while while doing his time
all right cameron lindsay thank you so
much for being with us tonight and for
your insights i appreciate it very much
thank you brian and we'll have full
coverage on friday of the sentencing of
derrick shelton coming up next
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree with the choices
made by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who
is the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire
innate let's begin with the winner
you've chosen john berman at
cnn for his interview with new york
mayor candidate
eric adams so your specific problem was
the date they decided
to campaign together if they had
campaigned together yesterday on june
20th you would have been okay with it
i would have looked at something
differently i think you sent the wrong
signal in the wrong message and that is
what how many of the african-american
hispanic candidates felt after they saw
it
some of your campaign supporters
suggesting somehow
that by doing this it works to suppress
the vote i'm not sure i understand how
that works well i can't speak on behalf
of my supporters but i do know this but
you disagree then that it's oppressive
no
no so tough questions from john berman
there for mr adams sort of playing the
race card i guess aiden
that's right so it's obviously election
day in new york today
and uh that man that you just saw is
very likely to be the next mayor
um he faced a tough interview from john
berman on new day with cnn's morning
show
yesterday on monday the genesis of the
clip is
our comments that eric adams made on the
subject of two of his rivals andrew yang
and catherine
garcia who have chosen to campaign
together adams attacks that alliance by
accusing those two candidates of seeking
to stop
a person of color from gaining higher
office um that comment from adams has
been
seen as sort of an odd and self-serving
um
invocation of racism uh in order to make
a political attack on his opponents
not to mention that andrew yang as he
pointed out in response as a person of
color himself
um so john berman did a good job
questioning adams about that comment on
cnn on monday
and adams i think failed to provide an
adequate response of why
he was casting uh the effort by his two
rivals
to team up and campaign together as
racist
all right and for loser once again
you've chosen tucker carlson at fox
beginning with his theory that somehow
the fbi was behind
the january 6th insurrection at the
capitol
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
so fbi operatives were organizing
the attack on the capital on january 6th
so aidan what do you say about that now
i know that we tucker carlson is very
often the subject of
our loser of the day um this segment
that he put out has prompted once again
a million fact checks and
outraged columns of his latest
controversial comments
this time it was claiming without any
evidence at all that the fbi
orchestrated the january 6th attack on
the capital
uh tucker halston has made efforts to
downplay the attack before and deflect
blame from trump
who is primarily responsible for the
horde of his supporters that ran back
the capitol building
but this time he made what legal experts
have described as an embarrassing
misreading of court documents
to claim that the fbi has been proven
to have orchestrated this attack on
january 6.
now while that controversy is fading ben
smith at the new york times dropped a
great priest on sunday night
that reported that carlson who attacks
journalists regularly on his show
is actually a secret source for many of
them um it was a pretty revealing look
behind the curtain and
certainly demonstrated some hypocrisy on
behalf of the fox news host
and what does that say about tucker
carlson that in one hand of passing on
these theories wild as they might be
and then on the other hand quietly
giving background information to
reporters of the so-called mainstream
media
about both fox news and about donald
trump
i think it's a worthy reminder that
tucker carlson has always been in media
he is
part of the media elite so the sort of
populist
character that he plays on his show well
he believes that a lot of those policies
and beliefs
um you have to remember that he you know
has worked in magazines since the 1990s
and is very much a cable news host um so
i think
that's worth remembering he talks to
journalists itself
and there was another piece of news
reportedly that he has decided
not to run for president as if that was
a possibility
yeah you know there's speculation about
him running for president has gone on
for a couple years
now since his fox news show blew up um i
asked him about it in an interview last
year and he laughed off the proposition
he's always denied that he has any plans
to run for president
i think it's safe to say with anyone
running for president
you don't really know what they want to
do until it comes to campaign season
and bottom line all this controversy
being chosen the loser again and again
i guess it's good for his ratings
i do think to a certain extent he revels
in the fact that not only is he the top
rated post on cable news
but also that he dominates the
conversation on twitter um
i think the the only one of the only
reasons that you can explain
why night after night he chooses to
provoke and cover such provocative
subjects uh in ways that often sparks
controversy is that he really likes
seeing his name in the new york times
um i think that's a good explanation for
why he covers some of the things that he
does
as any um so i think it helps with the
ratings and it also helps keep them in
conversation
great all right aidan thank you so much
and thank you all for watching tonight
and thanks to our great staff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you